let's talk about the upside because as
we know you will
never like again guys the day that our
grandfathers and great-grandfathers
lived in where they could go to a
warehouse and spend 35 years screwing in
caps on the toothpaste tubes they'll get
a gold watch at retirement and they go
home and get a pension everything's fine
they're gone J OBS don't pay well for
the most part yeah that's the 909 % of
them out there there's a few small jobs
that do pay quite well I'll get into
that right now so there's really Six
Paths to wealth in my estimation get a
pen and write these down these are also
going in the followup to my unplugged
Alpha book so the next book that's
coming out early next year and an
expanded chapter with more explanations
but I'm going to run them down for you
here
um the first is seet jobs so let's talk
about my mentor at the credit and
collection company who was the president
of the company I was assigned to him I
think he picked me actually if I'm not
mistaken because we had a manager
meeting and everybody was assigned a
mentor and you know there was a mentor
and a
mentees uh deal and I would go to his
office you know top floor of the
building uh once a week for two hours on
a Friday or something like that
and this was for like eight or nine
weeks it was awesome because I got to
actually sit there with a guy that
started out in an industry or similar
industry that I was currently working in
25 years prior so you have the
understanding you look there and there's
a big room there's a [__] telescope
in the corner looking up at the sky
massive [__] desk made out of
mahogany or cherry or something it's 27
feet wide and all that beautiful you
know setup I don't know what they were
comping the guy I would imagine pretty
close to seven figures um that was back
in the day which was quite a lot of
money and you know genuinely nice guy
open to having the conversations I'd ask
him how he got started what did he to do
how did he get promoted um you know what
does he see as my strengths the
weaknesses he was asking me questions we
had a great Rapport going back and forth
uh enjoy it so this is one of the
benefits that you can get if you're
working at Job look for opportunities
within the organization to be useful the
big problem that I see most people do
when it comes
to corporations and trying to climb the
corporate ladder and advancements and
all this sort of thing um even in my
world like you know as an entrepreneur I
get a lot of hey you know can I pick
your brain can I buy you a coffee and
pick your brain no [__] I can
buy my own coffee and I'm going to sit
there for 30 minutes while you ask me
questions that I've already answered
probably in my book or videos or
something like that when I could be
billing you know five grand an hour for
my time privately um when guys at this
level here can I pick your brain but
they basically he is can I steal your
time and pick your pocket right um time
is money time is valuable so you want to
look for opportunities within an
organization if you're in it with opport
with with scale hundreds of employees
you know for example hey is there a
mentorship program can I you know can I
uh get time with the vice president with
the president with the regional whoever
with the whatever so I can advance my
career right uh you express interest in
these things to the appropriate people
and they want to hear that from you
believe it or not like I think when I
was running my de business I think I had
one
guy and I must have hired I don't know
60 or 70 people during that period of uh
time I had one guy out of the bunch that
said to me hey Rich can I you know can I
work after hours I come in the weekend
you know is there something you know
that I can be be doing that would be
useful so you know I can get some menhip
from you sort of thing not a lot of
people think about this and it's an
exceptional way to get into the first
role which is a true path to wealth
which is a c site job C CEO CFO CTO
doesn't matter what it is coo anything
Chief something officer right whether
you're in finance technology whatever it
happens to be executive um seet jobs pay
a lot of money the larger the
organization with the greater the
revenue the more money you'll get paid
now it's a pyramid there's one guy at
the top or if you take like you know top
triangle of the pyramid there's one CEO
CFO Co CT there like four or five let's
say main C jobs so there's five out of
an organization that might have you know
400 uh people that work for right so
it's very very small but those jobs are
only available to the ones that put in
the time and they do the work and they
put in the extra hours and they ask the
questions how can I be useful they overd
deliver they bring more value to the
company than anybody else and it is
known it is obvious to all the powers
that be that is happening now while
you're doing by way you're lining go
because you're working like [__] C
the extra time you're asking questions
you're helping out other people you're
usually you know at least 1.5 to two
times more productive than the average
employe in the company I would say aim
for at least two times maybe three times
more productive you need to put yourself
out there to make yourself known like
this is how you ascend into these
positions they just don't hand them out
at the front door and go oh uh you're an
entitled person so let me give this to
you right doesn't work that way um it's
never gonna work that way even even with
quotas and agendas and all this other
[__] they got going on today it's
never goingon to go that
way so that's the first one SE sweet
jobs true path to wealth right uh the
next one is a licensed professional
licensed professional could be um doctor
lawyer accountant uh licensed with uh
you know financial instruments do loans
investment products uh
Insurance um even real estate you know
some degree but that's more in like high
ticket sales but um anything that's a
licensed professional to perform a
certain task with a governing body like
if you become a lawyer here in Ontario
you've got the Upper Canada Law Society
that governs your uh practices um
doctors have a similar governing body so
all of these things exist um they pay
really well you know like um an a an
orthodontist the dentist like like top
tier 500,000 00,000 a year uh could be a
little bit more in the states probably a
little bit less in Canada by the way you
get paid a lot less for professional
jobs in Canada versus state so if you're
considering a career with a professional
designation myice is to move to the
states find a way to get your ass South
of the Border and work to the states the
tax rate is lower and they pay a [__]
ton more and the cost of living is a lot
lower in the St
so Public Service
Announcement next one
um I call this category uh people that
command an audience okay uh it can be an
actor a musician uh an athlete and even
an influencer as dorky as that sounds
but anybody that has the attention of an
audience um and the greater the
attention they have the more they can
get paid so I don't know who the most
famous person is on Instagram right now
I think at one point it was Dwayne The
Rock Johnson bounce back and forth him
and Kim Kim Kardashian
or maybe even Dan B I don't know but any
of these guys with a massive audience uh
they get sponsorship deals it's easy for
them to promote movie like if they have
a role for a film they have the choice
between Dwayne Johnson and an unknown
name who's younger that has following of
I don't know half a million followers
versus The Rocks whatever it is 30 40 50
million followers they know that when
the movie gets out for promotion people
following him will get will see the
promotion in his feed sort of thing so
being able to command an audience can
pay you a lot of plus you get paid for
the movie you get paid for sponsorships
you get paid for any products you create
like a tequila brand shoes whatever it
happens to be thing with a right Michael
Jordan is Rich As [__] because of his
career um because he was getting the
attention of a lot of people there's
Netflix specials on guys like this like
if you're a guy like um Tyson Fury David
Beckham Michael Jordan like not only do
you have your sports career you have
your retirement career where you can now
sell your stories for books for film
things like that you get the point right
if you have the attention of people uh I
mean you lose privacy as one of the
consequences of that but if you have the
attention of people then you will get
paid well very very well in fact um
there's disadvantages of all these by
the way which I'll explain in a minute
but then the next one would be high
ticket sales right um when I was a
teenager I used to work at stereo store
and for every TV DVD player system
surround Sone setup you know that would
get set up or sold or whatever I get
paid a commission and the commission was
peanuts it was like 100 like less than
200 bucks most of the time uh per pay
cycle I made more money on the hourly
rate than I did on the on the commission
but the notion of commission as it
existed at the time I didn't think about
oh well if I can sell something then if
I can sell a stereo or a set of speakers
why don't I [__] sell something that
costs five million or 10 million or 50
million or 100 million or a billion
dollars because you get paid a
percentage of that I'm telling you this
right now High ticket sales pays very
well if you're if you're selling private
jets if you're selling Yachts if you're
selling expensive real estate if that
that's Market you're gonna nich to
you'll get paid very very well um they
have these shows on Netflix where these
annoying as hell women sell real estate
in California what's the called selling
Sunset somebody tell me in the chat and
it's like you know you'll see like the
listing price and it's like the
commission 6 00,000 it's like
$600,000 is the commission rate on
something that big and so Grand all you
have to do is flip a few of those per
year and you're set you're making a few
million bucks per year it is it is a
path to wealth um so if you're good at
sales s sh expensive simple next one is
stem stands for science technology
engineering and math you're a rocket
engineer for Elon Musk uh you're
research
a cure for cancer neurolink something
you know for musk or one of his projects
or you know things like that you can get
paid very very well um you know these
are into six figures for sure like I
said earlier I've I've talked to several
guys on coaching consults that work for
the fan companies it's interesting
because these guys get paid really
really well but they're so bad they're
so bad you they make eight $900,000 a
year and they just get screwed over by
these run them right
just I don't know
man if there was a way to get to these
guys before they went and screwed up
their life they could save a lot of
money but anyway um you know these guys
make seven eight 900,000 a year you know
uh some of the comp plans can be well
seven years depending on stock share
options and all that kind of stuff but
they get paid paid super well and then
the last one which we'll get into uh in
in more detail next week the next uh
unplugged Alpha is
entrepreneurship and out of everything
that I've mentioned it's it continues to
be my preferred path and as every year
goes by I think the value of it being
the preferred path dramatic I'll give
you one example right now um I think
over the last few years especially since
the scamdemic and the beer buug and the
wokeness and the BLM The George Floyd
and all this like all the stuff that's
happening um companies are now as a
function of embracing and endorsing and
virtue signaling to the world how
inclusive they are and how much they
love rainbows and people that cut off
their body parts because they want to
identify with whatever it is that they
want to identify and pronouns and all
the stuff people in these fields that
I've been mentioning are being forced to
comply with many of these agendas so
while you might make a lot of money as a
doctor or uh an athlete even like we've
seen athletes
um scrap with management you know with
the team um over forced you know clot
shots you know not wanting to take it
versus taking it and losing work
um that's not forced upon you as an
entrepreneur especially if you set up a
business the way that I describe in the
School of Entrepreneurship where where
uh you have the ability to maneuver it's
easy it's lucrative it's fun you can run
it from anywhere in the world there's no
employees that are required the way that
you structure it um when you set it up
properly and you've contemplated all
these things in the design and
Engineering of what you're building you
have something that is very profitable
very fun very maneuverable can be dealt
with from anywhere in the world I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out